eric watson has been talking about this
with gage theory so different different
kinds of approaches
from the physics world from the
mathematical world to
extend past this
scalar view of economics so gauge theory
is one way that comes from physics
do you find that
a way of exploring economics interesting
so outside of cryptocurrency outside of
the actual technologies and so on just
analysis of how economics works do you
find that interesting
yeah i i think that if we're going to
want to really make any scientific
progress in economics we have to apply
much
much more computationally intensive and
richer forms of mathematics
so simulation perhaps or
yeah you know when i was in mit i
studied system dynamics
you know they taught it at the sloan
school it was developed by jay forrester
who
who
was an extraordinary computer scientist
and um
when we created models
of
economic behavior they were all
multi-dimensional non-linear models so
if you want to describe how
anything works in the real world you
have to start with the concept of
feedback
if i double the price of something
demand will fall and attempts to to
create supply will increase and there
will be a delay
before the capacity increases there'll
be an instant demand
change and there'll be rippling effects
throughout every other segment of the
economy downstream and upstream of such
thing
so it's kind of common sense
but most economics most classical
economics it's always
you know taught with linear models
you know fairly simplistic linear models
and oftentimes even i'm really shocked
today
that the entire
mainstream dialogue of economics has
been captured by
scalar arithmetic
for example
if if you read
you know read any article in new york
times or the wall street journal right
they just refer to it there's an
inflation number or the the cpi or
the inflation rate is x
and if you look at all the historic
studies
of the impact of inflation generally
they're all based upon
the idea that inflation equals cpi and
then they try to extrapolate from that
and you just get nowhere with it
so
at the very least we should be
considering inflation and other
economics concept as a non-linear
dynamical system so non-linearity and
also just embracing the full complexity
of just how the variables interact maybe
through simulation maybe some
have some interesting models around that
wouldn't it be refreshing if somebody
for once published a table of the change
in price of every product every service
and every asset and every place
over time
you